you
[Applause]
Ashley Judd stupid [__] [__] you
can't sue someone for calling them a
[__] if you can't handle the Internet
[__] off [__]
I wish Ashley Judd would die a horrible
death she is the absolute worst Ashley
Judd you're the reason women shouldn't
vote twisted is such a bad movie I don't
even want to rape it whatever you do
don't tell Ashley judge he'll die alone
with a dried out vagina if I had to [__]
an older woman oh my god I would [__]
the [__] out of Ashley Judd that [__]
is hot a F the unforgivable [__] I would
do to her online misogyny is a global
gender rights tragedy and it is
imperative that it ends
girls and women's voices and our allies
voices are constrained in ways that are
personally economically professionally
and politically damaged and when we curb
abuse we will expand freedom I am a
Kentucky basketball fan so on a fine
March day last year I was doing one of
the things I do best I was cheering for
my Wildcats the daffodils were blooming
but the referees were not blowing the
whistle when I was telling them to bunny
they're very friendly to me before the
opening tip but they really ignore me
during the game three of my players were
bleeding so I did the next best thing I
tweeted it is routine for me to be
treated in the ways I've already
described to you it happens to me every
single day on social media platforms
such as Twitter and Facebook since I
joined Twitter in 2011 misogyny and
misogynists have amply demonstrated they
will dog my every step my spirituality
my faith being a hillbilly I can say
that you can't all of it is fair game
and I have responded to this with
various strategies
I've tried engaging people this one guy
was sending the hyper sexual nasty stuff
and there was a girl in his avatar and I
wrote him back and said is that your
daughter I feel a lot of fear that you
may think about and talk to women this
way and he surprised me by saying you
know what you're right I apologize
sometimes people want to be held
accountable this one guy was musing too
I don't know who that maybe I was the
definition of a [__] I was married to a
Scott for 14 years so I said cut means
did many different things in different
countries but I'm pretty sure you
epitomize the global standard of a dick
I've tried to rise above it I've tried
to get in the trenches but mostly I
would scroll through the social media
platforms with one eye partially closed
trying not to see it but you can't make
a cucumber out of a pickle what a scene
goes in it's traumatic and I was always
secretly hoping and some part of me that
what was being said to me and about me
wasn't true because even I an avowed
self declared feminist who worships at
the altar of Gloria internalized the
patriarchy this is really critical
patriarchy is not boys and men it is a
system in which we all participate
including me on that particular day for
some reason that particular tweet after
the basketball game triggered something
called
a cyber mob this vitriolic global
outpouring of the most heinous hate
speech death threats rape threats and
don't you know when I was sitting at
home alone in my nightgown I got a phone
call and it was my beloved former
husband and he said on a voicemail left
one what is happening to you is not OK
and there was something about him taking
a stand for me that night that allowed
me to take a stand for myself and I
started to write I started to write
about sharing the fact that I'm a
survivor of all forms of sexual abuse
including three rapes and the hate
speech I get in response to that these
are just some of the comments posted to
news outlets being told I'm a snitch is
really fun
thank you Jesus may your grace and mercy
shine so I wrote this feminist op-ed it
is entitled forget your team it is your
online gender violence toward girls and
women that can kiss my righteous ass and
I did that alone and I published it
alone because my chief adviser said
please don't the reign of retaliatory
garbage that is inevitable I fear for
you but I trust girls and I trust women
and I trust our allies it was published
in 2008 proves that every single day
online misogyny is a phenomenon endured
by us all all over the world and when it
is intersectional it is worse sexual
orientation gender identity race
ethnicity religion you name it it
amplifies the violence endured by girls
and women and for our younger girls it
is worse
it's clearly traumatizing our mental
health our emotional well-being are so
gravely affected because the threat of
violence is experienced
neurobiologically as violence the
cortisol shoots up the limbic system
gets fired we lose productivity at work
and let's talk about work our ability to
work is constrained online searches of
women applying for jobs reveal nude
pictures of them false allegations they
have STDs their addresses indicating
that they are available for sex with
real examples of people showing up at
this house for said sex our ability to
go to school is impaired 96% of all
postings of sexual images and our young
people girls our girls our boys are 2 to
3 times more likely non-consensual e to
share images and I want to say a word
about revenge porn part of what came out
of this tweet was my getting connected
with allies and other activists who were
fighting for
safe and free internet we started
something called the speech project
curbing abuse expanding freedom and that
website provides a critical forum
because there is no global legal thing
to help us figure this out but we do
provide on that website a standardized
list of definitions because it's hard to
attack a behavior in the right way if
we're not all sharing a definition of
what that behavior is and I learned that
revenge porn is often dangerously Mis
applied it is the non-consensual sharing
of an image used tactically to shame and
humiliate a girl or woman that attempts
to pornography us our natural sexuality
is I don't know about yours pretty
gorgeous and wonderful and my expressing
it does not pornography make so I have
all these resources that I'm keenly
aware so many people in the world do not
I was able to start the speech project
with colleagues I can often get a social
media company's attention I have a
wonderful visit to Facebook HQ coming up
hasn't helped the idiotic reporting
standards yet I actually pay someone to
scrub my social media feeds attempting
to spare my brain the daily iterations
of the trauma of hate speech and guess
what I get hate speech for that oh you
live in an echo chamber well guess what
having someone post a photograph of me
with my mouth open saying they can't
wait to come on my face I have a right
to set that boundary
the miss distinction between virtual and
real is specious because the guess what
that actually happened to me once when I
was a child and so that tweet brought up
that trauma and I had to do work on that
but you know what we do we take all of
this hate speech and we disaggregate it
and we code it and we give that data so
that we understand the intersectionality
of it you know when I get porn when it's
about political affiliation when it's
about age when it's about all of it
we're gonna win this fight there are a
lot of solutions
thank goodness I'm going to offer just a
few and of course I challenge you to
create and contribute your own number
one we have to start with digital media
literacy and clearly it must have a
gendered lens kids schools caregivers
parents it's essential to shall we talk
about our friends in tech said with
dignity and respect the sexism in your
workplaces must end the global standard
for gender equality is the minimum
standard and guess what Silicon Valley
if L'Oreal in India in the Philippines
in Brazil and in Russia can do it you
can too
enough excuses only when women have
critical mass in every department at
your companies including building
platforms from the ground up will the
conversations about priorities and
solutions change and more love for my
friends in tech profiteering off
misogyny and video games must end I'm so
tired of hearing you talk to me at
cocktail parties like you did a couple
weeks ago in Aspen about how deplorable
hashtag gamergate was when you're still
making billions of dollars off games
that maim and dump women for sport basta
as the Italians would say
our friends in law enforcement have much
to do because we've seen that online
violence is an extension of in-person
violence in our country more girls and
women have been murdered by their
intimate partners then died on 9/11 and
have died since in Afghanistan in Iraq
combined and it's not cool to say that
but it is true we care so much
geopolitically about what men are doing
over there to women over there in 2015
seventy two thousand eight hundred
twenty eight women used intimate partner
violence services in this country that
is not counting the girls and women and
boys who needed them law enforcement
must be empowered with up-to-date
Internet technology the devices and an
understanding of these platforms how
they work the police wanted to be
helpful when Amanda has called about the
death threat she was getting on Twitter
but they couldn't really when they said
what's Twitter our legislators must
write and pass astute legislation that
reflects today's technology and our
notions of free and hate speech in New
York recently the like law could not be
applied to a perpetrator because the
crimes must have been committed even if
it was anonymous they must have been
committed by telephone in mail by
telegraph the language must be
technologically neutral so apparently
I've got a pretty bold voice so let's
talk about our friends white men you
have a role to play and a choice to make
you can do something or you can do
nothing
we're cool in this room but when this
goes out everyone will say oh my god
she's a reverse racist
that quote was said by a white man
Robert Morris chairperson Price
Waterhouse Cooper he asked me to include
it in my talk we need to grow support
lines and help groups so victims can
help each other when their lives and
finances have been derailed we must as
individuals disrupt gender violence as
it is happening 92% of young people
29 and under witness it 72 percent of us
have witnessed it we must have the
courage and urgency to practice stopping
it as it is unfolding and lastly believe
her believe her this is fundamentally a
problem of human interaction and as I
believe that human interaction is at the
core of our healing trauma not
transformed will be trauma transferred
edith wharton said the end is latent in
the beginning so we are gonna end this
talk replacing hate speech with love
speech because i get lonely in this but
i know that we are allies i recently
learned about how gratitude and
affirmations offset negative
interactions it takes five of those to
offset one negative interaction and
gratitude in particular free available
globally anytime anywhere to anyone in
any dialect it fires the pre gen Ewell
anterior singlet a watershed part of the
brain that floods it with great good
stuff so i'm gonna say awesome stuff
about myself i would like for you to
reflect it back to me it might sound
something like this i am a powerful and
strong woman and you would say yes you
are my mama loves me i did a great job
with my talk
I have a right to be here I'm really
cute
God does good work and I love you thank
you so much for letting me be a service
[Applause]